ألم تسمعوا بالمثل
الذي يقول(عدو عدوي صديقي)؟
(لا تخافوا فالصين ستشتري غازي بنقودكم)
، هكذا قالها الرئيس الروسي!!!
هل هذه الكؤوس
هي شراب الاحتفال بالنصر
قبل الدخول في الحرب؟
وهل أعلنت روسيا والصين
بهذا الاحتفال تحالفهم أمام الملأ؟...
كيف تتلقى الولايات المتحدة
الرسائل الروسية الصينية المشتركة؟
وما هي تداعياتها على الأزمة
الأخيرة بين موسكو والغرب؟
وما هو سبب الغضب الأمريكي
من هذا التحالف؟
توحدت الجبهة لمواجهة الضغوط الغربية،
بتحالف غير مسبوق
وصفقات بمئات المليارات،
بين الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
والرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ.
فما أهمية التنسيق بين الطرفين؟
وما تأثيره في الاستقرار الدولي؟
.....
توافق غير مسبوق  في العلاقات
الروسية الصينية،
بمجرد أن قرعت هذه الكؤوس،
يأتي من خلفهم شراكة استراتيجية
بين بوتين وشي جين بينغ،
صفقات التبادل التجاري بينهما،
وصلت  لمئة وأربعين مليار دولار
وارتفاع حجم إمدادات الغاز الروسي
للصين إلى ثمانية وأربعين مليار متر
مكعب سنويا،،
الصين تؤكد على جهودها مع روسيا
لحماية مصالحهما، وهو ما تجسد
في بيان مشترك حيث جددت الصين
دعمها  للمطالب الروسية بضمانات أمنية ملزمة،
في وقت يحتد فيه النقاش مع الغرب
بشأن توسع الناتو شرقا،،،،
السفن الحربية لكل من روسيا وإيران والصين
تجري مناورات بحرية مشتركة
مجموعة من سفن أسطول المحيط الهادئ الروسي
تتألف من طراد "فارياغ" الصاروخي
وسفينة "أدميرال تريبوتس" الكبيرة
المضادة للغواصات
وناقلة "بوريس بوتوما" البحرية الكبيرة
تقف حاليا في ميناء جابهار بجمهورية إيران الإسلامية".
فما هي ردة فعل الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية على ذلك؟
احتسى الرئيسان كأسين من العصير
هما أشبه بشراب الانتصار،
على الرغم أن الحرب لم تبدأ بعد،
فهل يكون هذا لدبّ الرعب في قلوب الأمريكان؟
عندما التقى بوتين بنظيره الصيني،
تم الإعلان عن أقوى شراكة استراتيجية بينهما،
وتمخضت عنه صفقات للصينيين
مع شركات الغاز والبترول الروسية
بمئات المليارات من الدولارات.
في الوقت الذي يتصاعد فيه الخلاف
بين بوتين والمستوردين الأوروبيين
بشأن أوكرانيا.
....
تنديدات ضد أمريكا كما هي العادة،
وهنا ندد الحليفان: بالتأثير السلبي"
لنفوذ الولايات المتحدة على
"الاستقرار والسلام العادل" في العالم،
وأكدا أنهما "يعارضان أي توسيع للحلف الأطلسي
مستقبلاً"، وهو المطلب الأول لموسكو
من أجل خفض حدة التوتر بينها
وبين الغرب حول أوكرانيا.
مطلقين تحذيرا:
لبلدان "حلف شمال الأطلسي
إلى التخلي عن نهجه المؤدلج
الذي يعود إلى الحرب الباردة"،
وهو موقف تكرره روسيا باستمرار.
(الاقتصاد أولا)
يهتم الطرفان بتأمين الجانب الاقتصادي
قبل أن يخوضا المعركة ضد أمريكا وحلف الناتو
إذا ما وقفوا في صف أوكرانيا،
لذلك فإن مبيعات الغاز وحدها
قد تدر حوالي 37.5 مليار دولار
على مدى فترة محددة،
على افتراض متوسط سعر للغاز
يبلغ 150 دولاراً لكل ألف متر مكعب،
حسبما أشارت شركة الغاز الروسية العملاقة
"غاز بروم" بخصوص صفقتها الحالية مع الصين.
ويقدر الحليفان أن الصفقة ستمتد إلى
ما بين ٢٥ إلى ٣٠ عام،
روسيا التي تعد  أكبر مورد للغاز الطبيعي لأوروبا،
ها هي تزيد من قلق الدول الغربية
من أن الإمدادات غير المستقرة بالفعل
قد تنقطع في حالة نشوب صراع،،
هذا التحالف الذي يؤرق الولايات المتحدة،
جاء ردا على إنشاء تحالف "أوكوس"
العسكري بين الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا وأستراليا.
التحالف  مع الصين يضع روسيا
متقدمة خطوات على الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
بل ويجعلها تمضي قدما لغزو أوكرانيا،
في حين أن أمريكا ربما لن تستطيع الرد
والوقوف مع أوكرانيا كما وعدت،
حتى أن هذا التحالف يهدد الأمن الدولي عموما،
ويقلق سكينته،،
تحالفت الصين مع روسيا
بانتظار مزيدا من المتحالفين معهما،
ليكون هذا هو وقت إنهاء هيمنة القطب الواحد،
أو الهيمنة الأمريكية،
فما هي فاعلة أمريكا لترد على هذا التحالف؟
لأن استمرار هكذا تحالفات يعني بداية
عصر الانهيار بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
فما هي أولى الضربات التي سيوجهها
تحالف الدب الروسي مع التنين الصيني لأمريكا؟